the weekend
performs yep and everybody's thinking
this entire time did you guys think the
artists got paid for doing a halftime
super bowl
yeah i thought they did the jew paul did
you i thought they made like a meal
i thought they made some kind of money
so apparently every performer that
performs during super bowl halftime show
never gets paid beyonce bruno mars
they get scale i mean scale is like not
that much money though you're not
talking about like a million bucks or 10
million
can you check to see if michael jackson
got paid for halftime show because if
michael jackson didn't get paid he was
like the king right what year was he
doing
a long time 1990 yeah that was a while
back when he did it
so beyonce to bruno mars have
essentially worked for free despite
selling out stadiums on world tours most
halftime a-listers
are reportedly paid union scale which is
a fraction
of a six or seven figure sums they take
on the reg
according to forbes it's usually worth
the underpaid label for these stars
since they could get as many as 104
million set of eyeballs on them at no
cost to them it usually ends up to a big
spike in sales for example last year's
halftime performers
jaylon shakira collectively sold 21 000
song downloads an increase of 893
percent
able weekend spent almost
7 million dollars of his own money
beyond the
already generous budget to make his
halftime show be what he envisioned
seven million dollars a rep for the star
told the post so what are your thoughts
good idea not getting paid they should
get paid what'd you find
first of all who's that michael jackson
he asked for a million dollars a seeming
bargain but the nfl did not pay its
halftime performers a policy that
remains
wow good for the nfl good for the nfl
and good for michael jackson but good
for the nfl
for not paying a million bucks and they
took a stand yeah that's eyeballs you
got their thoughts
yeah i mean the last sentence you said
abel which is the weeknd's
real name spent seven million dollars of
his own money beyond the already
generous budgets that they make for the
halftime show yeah
so what i would do is i would insert the
word invested
seven million dollars of his own money
rather than spent because it's all about
roi
and i'll give a case example pat patrick
bett david host of the bet david podcast
show
did you know who the weeknd was before
the super bowl no clue you had no clue
who he was i i knew him i knew two of
his songs
there's my point you when when i when
when i first moved to dallas this was uh
you told me
he's he's a level below michael jackson
i said he can sing like michael jackson
he's got the moves but he doesn't have
the moves like michael jackson
but the point is you did not know who
the weeknd was no but
you were playing his hit song blinding
lights
on repeat over for a month over and over
and over again
and pat said i have no clue who what i
didn't know is the fact that he was the
guy that did a face surgery which was
all fake it was all the publicity stuff
leading into this of course
brilliant move by the way and he had all
the bandaged people dancing around like
there were zombies in three
reminiscent of some michael jackson
stuff but even pat who was listening to
blinding lights
literally on repeat like i remember
playing ping pong and the song was just
there's no questions
still had no clue who the weeknd was
even though you listen to his song
so it just shows you can have a hit song
and nobody knows who you are pat
do you know who the weekend is now no
question about it you know exactly i
gotta tell you man
in my opinion but some people like oh he
sucked you know his performance wasn't
this
i thought it was amazing i was literally
entertained yes
and you could hear his voice because you
know sometimes these types of things av
is off the sound is not really good
you're singing we're like yeah i can't
really hear you
sing that well i thought he crushed it i
thought the setting was amazing i
thought the set was amazing
i thought the performance was amazing
when they walked on the field at the end
as a player i was a little bit ticked
off i'm like listen man if you
create one little you know uh area divot
where i can trip over you know
the guy instead of getting the first
down you you get it that's probably why
kansas city chiefs got crushed you know
it was all there was zero touchdowns
yeah but uh
but i thought it was amazing so you're
saying the investment of seven million
dollars of his own money was a good idea
i'm saying that's a lot of money right
i'm saying whether what number one
not getting paid completely
understandable now look at the eyeballs
it's free marketing publicity it's
everything i mean this thing says 21 000
song downloads that means you made 21
thousand dollars
okay what what 21 000 song downloads me
is what
seven million yeah i'm not sure what
paul what does 21 000 song downloads
mean at 99 cents
oh that's one song though i can't do
math that fast
okay so listen now you're talking about
the weekend who maybe
you know let's say 50 million people
knew who he was i'm just making an
example now
250 million but let's just say it's
people
million though yeah stage wise what is
the a bigger place to perform as an
artist than like say super bowl i mean
there's only been 47 that's it
performers that's that's the number one
place to
perform i really want to know here's
what it is world cup finals
okay world cup finals but is it the same
level and they don't even do
entertainment
no they don't they don't have they don't
have because it's short inner boom they
go yeah
if you had a chance so i would say
probably it's the biggest
show it is the biggest show is it bigger
than the uh olympics opening in case
there's nothing bigger than this
bigger than the super bowl and the
olympics that's why roger gordon makes
40 million here and got a private jet
and health insurance for the rest of his
life
it's a legitimate worldwide audience so
you're saying the seven million was
worth a weekend spending the seven
minutes absolutely
do you think he set the tone for
everybody else in the future to also
spend a part of their money
or no you think this is just like again
i'm using the word investing not
spending
this is an investment in your career
notoriety beyonce didn't need to do that
she was already yeah a world everyone
knew beyonce she didn't need to do it so
we couldn't
get out of beyonce yet no no but he's
probably
put it this way pat he's probably you
didn't even know who the weeknd was you
definitely know who he is now no
probably your whole family knows who he
is yeah if the weekend goes to a concert
and
here in miami you might now even take
your family oh i know the weekend
now he's making money now are you okay
mario said he doesn't listen to the
weekend monday through friday
that's true that was a joke that was a
mario oh that's the guys
mario's stand up actually oh you know
mario's joke listen i would tell you any
comedians in florida hang out with mario
for one night you will at least get 10
jokes from mario
yes or no you may have the audience walk
out but you will get 10 jokes
from mario okay all right so you're
saying it was worth the seven minutes
what are your thoughts on this so i'd
i'd just be curious about what he spent
compared to other people
uh have to other halftime performers and
if the budget is lower this year than it
is other years
uh given that there's with the audience
less people watching
uh ads i mean we've talked about ads
pulling out
so maybe there's a lower budget and then
he made up for it
that would be something that he cares
about what what is the uh
qualification like who votes for it i
wonder like who says this year we're
using the weekend like how do you
campaign for that
is it the nfl but i wonder is it a
campaign or is it a
hey weekend you got the spot it's you
like how does
you know how you lobby to say we want
the olympics to be
in such and such country how is there is
there a form of lobbying for it
i i'm sure there might be slight
lobbying you know agents are always
that's their job
but it would be a similar process to you
know kind of how
we choose do you think a part of the
seven million is the money he paid to
the nfl to be the halftime show guy like
do you think you know what i'm saying
it might be yeah what i'm saying because
i see where we're going with this where
it's like hey
nfl i'll give you three million bucks
let me do the halftime and then if i was
like okay we'll take another three
million dollars
i don't think the nfl needs three
million dollars okay but i mean to put
it in perspective guys
i see where you're going here sort of
with the conspiracy theory on the
weekend here i mean let's let's look at
let's look
correct me if i'm wrong paul has there
ever just been
one singular performer just
not named michael jackson who just
performs by himself like think about it
shakira and j.lo perform together you
had maroon 5 a whole group
they brought on like the rolling stones
very good you brought you had might you
had
justin i think she sang the national
anthem that's i don't think she was the
performer yeah you had justin timberlake
with janet jackson he ripped off the you
know the titty that was a famous thing
uh respect to that um but just though
even bruno mars had his whole crew vibe
the bruno mars cast or whatever it
all starts just the weekend one dude
yeah
you know okay i mean i'm sold listen
yeah i'm with you good for him
conspiracy theory good for him so he you
know there may have been something going
on prince
2007 by himself yeah but prince is
prince beyonce 2013.
that's another mount rushmore new kids
on the block 1991 that's nice
wait new kids on the block 1991 that's
huge
black eyed peas okay but you had fergie
of will i am you got the other two
yahoos you i mean
that's a whole group you got the florida
a m band 1971.
sam you flam you respect to famu if
you're a fam you
respect okay uh you go diana ross 1996.
youtube 2000. okay you're talking
beyonce you're talking
beyonce is the modern day diana ross i
mean people forget like
she was the beyonce of the 70s i want to
say 60s
okay but the weekend just went from
yeah i kind of know that guy he's pretty
big to
you know mount rushmore music status
super bowl drew higher tv ratings in
boston and tampa plenty of patriots fans
still love to watch tom brady according
to
our and uh i don't know what you have
over there boston generated a rating of
57.6 which means 57.6 percent of all the
tvs in the market were turned to the
game
in boston in tampa that number was 52.3
there's only one tv i care about
what's that bill belichick i just care
if bill belichick's
was turned on the 57.6 rating in boston
surpasses the rating generated there for
all but one of patriots super bowl
appearances which is quite frankly an
amazing
outcome so boston even though they lost
brady they still
love the guy okay and even patriots send
a tweet
afterwards giving him love when he won
which was a classy move
done by p i'm almost certain that was
bill belichick because he's a big
tweeter i can almost see that happening
so what do you think about this uh so i
have a theory about this i think
part of the reason is that um when it
comes when a team is winning
when you create a dynasty there's more
followers a lot of casual fans don't
care about sports unless you're winning
i can see that
and tampa i don't know when they won the
super bowl last but it's been
sad 2000 2000 2000
long time ago okay that's a long time
2002 yeah 2003
uh and i mean with with the patriots
they've been in what
nine super bowls since 2002 so obviously
you have a lot of casual fans that then
start
jumping on the bandwagon so to speak and
i think now that even though he's left
they're still football fans in general
and then also
obviously that he was basically born and
bred in in
boston i mean you have 19 years versus
one year of a track record right
so you have 19 years of rooting for
brady versus
in a coved plagued season somehow
the goat ends up in the super bowl and
you're a casual tampa bay fan and you
you you might watch super bowl but let's
not forget
uh you know the level of sports fans and
we'll use the story from this past
weekend
you know you go to green bay for example
what are you doing on the weekend you're
watching the packers play
straight up i mean you're in new england
in the middle of winter
you're watching tom brady play we walked
into a sports bar on
in miami this weekend and it was pretty
funny
and it was it was it was pat his kids
you guys showed up
and uh you know we were getting lunch we
were hungry we were
it was a packed uh shout out to my my
boy rudy who runs
top 42 uh alex rudolph down in miami
free commercial for the top 42 crowd uh
go go get the uh
the hot plates there but the point is
the place is packed people are
celebrating birthdays
it's a level up on yard house and
paco's i go i go i asked the waitress i
go
this place is pretty packed today yeah
and uh she's like yeah you know our
bottomless brush
goes but don't forget you know
university of miami is playing v-tech
and basketball i go pat
dude that's there's nobody here watching
a random college basketball game
in miami he's like really that's that's
not why people are here i go no
we're in miami yeah we're in miami miami
he's playing virginia tech i said hi
72 to 70. yeah it's going into like
double overtime they should i go i go
past it's not
it's not bama and i looked around yeah
literally
no one was watching the screen i said
pat we're in miami there's nightclubs
there's
you know you can go jet ski and you can
go anywhere you want you can do field
trips you can go to the beach
nobody's sitting around watching a
random college directly take a shot
at the folks in boston dude
what was that movie was it was it i
don't know what movie was if it was ben
affleck
if it was goodwill hunting where ben
affleck tells uh
uh tells uh what's his name and he says
man i'm so sick of the
you know the women in boston i gotta
leave this place i think there is a line
there somewhere i don't know where it
was
yeah and he had he wanted to leave so
yesterday i was i was talking to uh
nicholas ingram who's a sniper
okay and he has 33 confirmed kills
irving
i'm sorry nicholas irving who has 33
confirmed kills is what he has
in a span of like uh 90 days or 100 days
pretty intense all in afghanistan
yeah three or four months and uh i said
what city are you and he says san
antonio i said how do you feel about san
antonio says i can't stand it i said
neither does charles barkley you know
charles barkley always takes shots
at san antonio so today uh new england i
just want you to know
adam sosnick adam adam
saw snake if you want to make sure you
send him a message the fact that he took
a shot at boston you can reach it oh
yeah i mean let's
talk listen you know
if you want them smart and pale go to
boston if you want them dumb and tan
come on down to miami so
i'd like something maybe in the middle
so there we go i took a shot at both
cities
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye